a new dawn at the White House a congress
divided by a country split and it could
be further pulled apart but the
president is claiming victory
celebrating what he won not lost last
night the Republican Party defied
history to expand our Senate Majority
while significantly beating expectations
in the house you're a man who likes to
win but last night was not an absolute
victory for you beyond I'll be honest I
thought it was a very close to complete
victory I really believe that we have a
chance to get along very well with the
Democrats and if that's the case we can
do a tremendous amount of legislation
and get it approved
but as he entertained peace with the
other side of the aisle he went again to
war with the press that's enough that's
enough that's enough that's enough put
down the mic mr. president are you
worried about indictments coming down in
this investigation this is a president
who feels vindicated and freshly
emboldened before he spoke he'd already
sack two Attorney General Jeff Sessions
unable to forgive him for accusing
himself from the Russia probe it is fuel
to the fire for Trump's opponents whose
power may lie in investigating him
Democrats may well now beat the drums
demanding his tax returns subpoenas and
more on the Russia investigation with
his attorney general now out that is not
going away the Democrats have the
majority in the house though they are
sounding some notes of compromise we'd
like to work together so our legislation
will be bipartisan we're not going for
the lowest common denominator we're
going for the boldest common denominator
there was no blue wave a ripple was
enough they needed 23 seats they got 26
their strategy of targeting women
minorities and the young paid off it was
a night of firsts to New York Democrat
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes becoming the
youngest woman elected to Congress but
Trump made these midterms about the
Senate and in Missouri a telling tale of
his success Thank You mr. president for
your leadership thank you for believing
in Missouri tonight the people of
Missouri have delivered through all the
talk of stars and surges in Texas one of
the freshest faces on the Left failed
Ted Cruz hanging on in a surprisingly
tight boat against former punk rocker
battling with Hollywood coming in
against the state with the national
media coming in against the state but
all the money in the world was no match
for the good people of Texas America is
far from letting go of Donald Trump and
he may well have a winning formula for
his next fight but there are now two
parties with two bases and two
ideologies
and some treacherous years ahead
Cordelia lent Sky News Washington